Tina Turner's son Ronnie has died he was
62 years old Tina's grieving her son on
social media quote Ronnie you left the
world far too early in sorrow I closed
my eyes and think of you my beloved Son
Ronnie's father Ike Turner died in 2007.
I wanted those children I wanted to be a
mother one of the things that was high
on the list was to get married and have
children in the beginning that was
Mother and Entertainer they say things
like God mother you know you you're
something else or something like that
you know because to them I haven't
changed in a statement to ET the LAPD
officers responded to a death
investigation at Ronnie's home Thursday
morning TMZ reports that in a call to
9-1-1 Ronnie was said to be having
trouble breathing then stopped breathing
and was pronounced dead at the scene
when paramedics arrived Ronnie's death
comes four years after Tina lost her
firstborn son Craig who took his own
life in 2018. I think Craig was lonely
that's what I think really got him more
than anything else I have pictures all
around of him smile and I I think I'm
sensing that he's in a good place I
really do Ronnie was an accomplished
musician and made a cameo in his
mother's biopic What's Love Got to Do
With It Ronnie's wife affida confirmed
the tragic news on Instagram calling him
her best friend and telling her husband
to rest in paradise